Well,
hello, how are you saying hello to Héctor Mejía?
This is a news item for today, Thursday
, April 22, a shooting on the strip is being investigated. At
the moment, it is known that a
victim is recovering from
a gunshot wound. This happened over
Las Vegas' Flamengo powder  At
around 2:30 in the morning, authorities
said the suspect is a
fugitive. For more details and
updates, visit our
Disney Dotcom Diagonal page in Spanish.
Clark County leaders will meet
for a briefing on the
process to follow if you are stopped.  police
the session in spanish will be tonight
starting at
5pm you can watch this session
through the clark county facebook page
and many companies are
hiring as las vegas' slowly returns
to normal the street  will have
a job fair today from 10 in the morning
to 4 in the afternoon you can fill out an
application on the golden page and nt
cover yourself pun  tocom after selecting
the new applicants option you
can click on strike and now we go to
the weather forecast the winds in the
valley died down after reaching 40
miles per hour yesterday we will have
sunny skies today reaching
80 degrees for this  afternoon I have a
nice newspaper héctor mejía and this was his
brief informative about going to a espanyol
[Music]